[Music]
everywhere I go last couple of weeks
ever since we put that out people come
up to me on the street and go phony
phone I've got to get it right I got to
get it right you help me you help me
first of all congratulations this
movie's a monster yes Lee successful
broke records yes number one movie in
the country uh biggest opening for
Martin Luther King weekend of any movie
and I'm very proud of it and thank
everybody for going to see it yeah well
I this brings me to my point I think
that video we made that thing blew up I
think that helped the movie I think I
deserve a piece okay so what I think a
piece of what a piece of wood you made
you made a wads of cash on that film I
think I need a cut I need I talked to
somebody but man I didn't make all the
money you better talk to Universal y'all
made a whole lot of money I didn't make
all don't nobody that you got money and
you were Kevin Hart both got money and I
got nothing you got money you got
do you need my money don't screw with me
cubed oh man what am I gonna do you
don't want a piece of this
[Applause]
you know some will lose no sleep okay
how about this there's gonna be a sequel
you know that okay guys could you throw
me a bone could I have just a small part
in the sequel maybe yeah yeah you might
get out party see really could I be some
kind of a badass I got a role for you
you got a role for me okay what you
gonna play the white guy we need for
crossover dollars that's what you will
call it white along - all right I'm
there I'll be that guy hello fellows
you'll bring in the crossover dollars
that's it that's what I'm doing the
crossover dollars
I gotta compliment you you've got and I
we've talked about this before but even
when we were shooting that remote
because we spent a couple of hours
together in that car you have the best
pissed-off face of anybody I've ever met
anybody you have just the best natural
and was this all your life when you were
a kid did people always think you were
mad even when you weren't mad people
always think I'm pissed off people
always think I'm mad about some I could
be at Disneyland and they think I'm mad
you know I mean it's just it's just the
way I look you served me well in some
ways and it's hurting me in some ways
you think it's purchase my yeah
what about like people must get confused
like they see or feel like like what's
the face that you would make if you just
found out you won the lottery oh oh yeah
got it okay
[Applause]
and what's the face you're making love
to the most beautiful woman in the world
what's that face no problem got them
here you go fantastic
what about do you ever think okay I've
never thought yourself
I want to I want to stretch I'm gonna I
want to be in a romantic you know comedy
kind of thing I want to be that guy no
I'm not that guy I'm not that guy I
would never go see I would never be in a
movie that I won't go see so I'm not
that guy
you won't go see a romantic comedy no
not unless my wife drags me right
kicking and screaming yeah and then
what's the face you would make while you
were watching that movie
[Applause]
it's dark in the theater you might as
well close your eyes even when you're
asleep don't wake me up
I'm like a bear man you know you're back
here someone makes you up yeah I'm like
a beer what if I snuck into your house
and you were asleep fast asleep and it
like you get up you get shot
[Laughter]